chaque jour cette semaine nathanaël le
maire et david jouillat nous propose une
nouvelle balade en touraine pour des
vacances zone est déconnecté aujourd'hui
nathanel vous avez posé votre vélo pour
arpenter à pied les chemins de saint
martin oui une randonnée qui nous a
amenés ici nous sommes à la collégiale
saint martin dont la petite commune de
candes saint martin c'est la limite de
la de la région on est tout au bout de
l'indre et loire et c'est là qu'est mort
l'évêque de tour st-martin la randonnée
par angry c'est le lieu de la naissance
de martin c'est l'homme qui a coupé son
manteau en deux qui est très connu et
qui finalement tout au long de ce
parcours a laissé beaucoup de monuments
des églises aussi des fontaines un petit
patrimoine que nous avons pu découvrir
au rythme de la randonnée et je vous
propose ce soir de nous retrouver sur ce
parcours avec des pèlerins qui arpentent
les pas de saint martin merci nathanaël
on se retrouve donc ce soir à 19h dans
votre page était pour arpenter ensemble
un petit bout de ce chemin